it is 5 45 on your wednesday morning the
nevada highway patrol putting their
tweets
where their dash cams are troopers are
not letting some people
drive them crazy they just tweet about
man were they busy over labor day
weekend
you know what especially on the ride
back to southern california if you
follow the nhp twitter account
hope you don't mind seeing these again
if you don't follow them you should and
if you're not on social media
hope you enjoy the extra snark they were
serving up like this
so apparently this person's time is more
valuable than everyone else's because he
was pulled over
for using the shoulder as a travel lane
or
two more drivers whose time was too
precious to sit in traffic you know
the good springs justice court in jean
it's lovely in the month of december
those are the court dates that are being
put on the citations
the bottom line safety and this is why
you cannot drive on the shoulder
a tow truck driver pulling into the
shoulder was hit by somebody shoulder
driving no injuries were reported
kudos to the troopers because just about
anyone who has made that drive knows the
frustration of seeing
i'm gonna go ahead and say it idiot
drivers thinking the shoulder is an
okay place to drive it's not buckle up
drive carefully please put
on that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me with pictures
and video to traffic 8
8newsnow.com